ghislain chevrier les formateurs
enseignants et consultant billère
chevrier merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation directe sur rt france alors
des élèves qui vivent sous la pression
idéologique et sociale de l'islamisme
selon ce professeur comment est-ce que
cela se manifeste concrètement alors
écoutez tout d'abord il faut bien situé
aujourd'hui les enseignants font face
relativement à la question du contenu
qu'ils transmettent aux élèves a de plus
en plus de difficultés mais qui sont
connues depuis assez longtemps et donc
qu'ils sont accompagnés des
contestations de contenus sur bien sur
le thème de la shoah qui est le plus
connu mais aussi dès qu'on aborde les
dieux de l'homme par exemple la question
de la théorie de l'évolution donc il ya
une série de sujets qui sont relatifs à
la montée des affirmations identitaires
et qui font que effectivement les
enseignants sont de plus en plus prend
de plus en plus face les revendications
de remise en cause du contenu est
malheureusement accompagné aussi de plus
en plus de menaces qui sont liées à
l'affirmation donc d'une logique aussi
communautaire et d'une d'une montée
surtout chez les jeunes deux de moins de
35 ans comme l'institut montaigne l'a
suivi dans l'une de ses dernières
enquêtes et bien de de l' influence du
salafisme par exemple qui tend à ramener
vers l'affirmation de la charia et des
principes de la religion puisque ça
concerne essentiellement il faut bien le
dire les élèves qui sont issus vient de
ce qu'on appelle entre guillemets la
communauté musulmane
alors vous le disiez des menaces une
mère d'élève a notamment dit à ce
professeur de philosophie sous
protection policière que s'il continue à
parler d'islam il serait le deuxième
samuel pâtit une enquête a été ouverte
mais on le voit les menaces contre des
professeurs bien elle continue qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire selon vous pour que
cela cesse
alors je crois que comme dans bien des
domaines puisqu'on est aussi sûre en ce
moment l'examen de la loi de lutte
contre le séparatisme et je crois que la
chose la plus importante c'est bien sûr
de réaffirmer la république et ses
principes et l'école républicaine laïque
c'est à dire cette école donc qui
affirme le principe de la connaissance
du savoir au dessus des convictions et
des identités qui sont qui peuvent être
propre à chacun et et qui sont protégés
d'ailleurs par la loi précisément par le
fait de porter au dessus des différences
un certain nombre de choses que nous
mettons en commun et de l'affirmer ont
effectivement 200 confusion il ya bien
des années qu'on a laissé reculé aussi
la liberté d'expression on sait que
m'ont paru l'elysée du lot
pardonnez moi je vous coupe mais vous
disiez on a laissé faire depuis des
années les élus locaux est ce qu'ils ont
une part de responsabilité dans cette
dégradation selon vous alors c'est un
phénomène d'ensemble il est évident et
l'aéro l'a vu aux dernières élections
municipales comme beaucoup de d'affichés
électorales ont mis en avant d'un des
candidats de voile et donc on voit donc
le clientélisme politico-religieux être
aujourd'hui un des arguments électoraux
est l un des axes principaux de
l'argument électorale donc effectivement
ça contribue aussi à donner le sentiment
que de mettre la religion c'est
finalement sur le même plan que tous les
autres contenus et favorisant une
certaine confusion qui va créer les
conditions chez les élèves dans l'école
elle même de contredire le contenu de
l'enseignement et de contes et de
considérer que si c'est cette opposition
n'est pas prise en compte
et bien c'est une manière d'insulter
leur religion donc là il faut il faut
absolument lever des confusions et comme
je le disais tout à l'heure
tels que gérard collomb lorsqu'il a
quitté ses responsabilités mise de
l'intérieur du disait on
on vit côte-à-côte aujourd'hui on risque
de vivre va ça passe de plus en plus du
fait de la dégradation et bien des
repères communs mairie dont
effectivement qui découlent pour une
part est effectivement de la façon dont
les élus gèrent aussi leur relation à la
république merci beaucoup ghislain
chevrier d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
dans la matinale de rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes formateurs
enseignants consultants